[Musique]
aucun autre s'ouvre un inconnu au même
âge une réussite telle que celle de
françois 1er
son règne fut le plus brillant et le
plus créatif de l'histoire de france de
culture exceptionnelle s'unir celle de
la france gothique et de la renaissance
italienne
françois 1er assez tôt a eu le sentiment
que le roi de france devaient
s'intéresser aux arts et également aux
lettres il va créer un univers de la
peinture de la littérature
[Musique]
comme nous l'avons vu dans l'épisode
précédent françois d'angoulême fut
élevée tel un prince de la renaissance
mais il était encore empreint de
l'esprit du moyen-âge lorsqu'il naît à
cognac en 14 294 la france est encore
sous influences gothiques
mais les nouveaux courants artistiques
qui se développe depuis un siècle en
italie et sème doucement vers le nord le
père de françois charles compte
d'angoulême meurt en 14 190 est suivi de
près par le roi valois charlot 8
ainsi le petit garçon âgé de 4 ans
devient-il à son tour compte d'angoulême
et en tant que fils aîné de cette maison
branche de celle des valois il est
désormais le premier prince de sang
[Musique]
sans pouvoir en être certaine sa mère
louise de savoie voient en lui le
nouveau roi de france avec sa fille
soeur de françois la célèbre poétesse
marguerite de navarre
elles vont consacrer leur vie à sa
réussite
elles vont lui transmettre l'amour des
arts et des lettres ainsi qu'une grande
curiosité intellectuelle
mais comme tous garçons du début du
xvième siècle le jeune prince a la tête
pleine d'histoires de chevalerie de
conquête et donne
l'italie avait été au centre des
préoccupations des rois précédent en
matière de politique étrangère
tout jeune françois s'imaginer en train
de conquérir un jour ce pays berceau du
monde civilisé
à la mort de louis xii en 15/100 15
il monte sur le trône et devient
françois 1er deux mois à peine après son
couronnement
il franchit les alpes et remporte une
grande victoire militaire à marignan
prenant ainsi le contrôle du duché de
milan portes de l'italie pour les
français
en quinze 119 pour asseoir sa réputation
françois se porte candidat à la couronne
impériale sa défaite au profit de
charles quint le habsburg récemment
couronné qui gouvernent l'espagne
l'autriche et quelques autres petits
territoires voisins de la france crée
inévitablement une rivalité entre les
deux monarques ce second épisode
consacré à la vie de françois 1er
présente les quatre guerres qu'il mena
tout au long de son règne il pratiquera
toujours une politique indécise si l'on
excepte quelques éclairs de génie et ne
parviendra jamais à la gloire militaire
qu'on lui prédisait c'est sa passion
pour la beauté la connaissance et l'art
de la renaissance qui le conduiront à
des succès d'un autre genre il restera
célèbre comme mécène car il apportait la
culture française à un niveau sans
précédent
c'est ainsi que s'est construite son
image de roi de la renaissance fin 15
124 françois hâte de rompre avec la
malchance en 15 120 il n'a pas réussi à
s'allier avec henri 8 d'angleterre pour
contrer l'empereur nouvellement élu
charles quint en case de 121 menant sa
première guerre contre l'empereur son
manque d'expérience le conduit à la
perte de milan
puis en 15/100 22 et 15 à 123 son manque
de tact pousse le connétable de bourbon
à se ranger aux côtés de son ennemi
françois premier aborde la bataille de
pavie dans un esprit de revanche les
français ont été chassés du duché de
milan par les impériaux au cours des
mois qui ont précédé la bataille et le
roi veut revivre la grande aventure
d'une victoire comme marignan 15 115 et
reconquérir 1,6 une terre cpt dont ils
se considèrent le seigneur la lombarde
il est clair qu'il manque d'alliés dans
sa lutte contre l'empereur romain
germanique et il est impatient de
reconquérir milan en octobre
il commence à préparer une nouvelle
offensive ces conseillers tentent de
l'en empêcher et le pressent de différé
jusqu'au printemps
mais françois et las d'attendre il veut
agir avant que ses adversaires ne se
regroupe
après avoir levé le siège autour de
marseille le 17 octobre le roi de france
confie la régence à sa mère est franchie
pour la deuxième fois les haltes le 28
octobre
les français entrent dans mille ans par
un côté tandis que la coalition impérial
la quittent par un autre et installe ses
garnisons dans la ville toute proche de
pavie françois décide d'assiéger pavie
initiative que les historiens
qualifieront plus tard de maladresse la
plupart de ses généraux lui conseille de
se retirer dans mille ans pour l'hiver
mais encore une fois françois ignore la
voix de l'expérience il est convaincu
que la garnison de pavie affamés sera
bientôt forcés de se rendre ils
sous-estiment la capacité d'endurance de
ses ennemis fin janvier les armées
impériales réuni delannoy vice roi de
naples et de charles connétable de
bourbon commandé par le marquis de
pescara sont en route vers la vie
en février les français prennent
position tout autour de pavie les
sécurise les rives de la verna vola au
sud de mirabel où l'ennemi lui ai posté
sur l'autre rive les troupes campent
dans la boue durant trois semaines
attendant que l'autre fasse le premier
pas lorsque la noix prend le 20 février
que pavie ne va pas pouvoir tenir
beaucoup plus longtemps
il comprend qu'il doit agir le 24
février aux alentours de minuit l'armée
impériale se déplace vers le nord en
longeant la rive est de la verna vol
il va lui falloir presque toute la nuit
pour creuser trois trous dans le mur du
parc à l'aube trois colonnes de soldats
pénètrent dans les brèches au lieu de
rester à l'abri dans son campement
françois premiers montent à l'assaut à 8
heures il se dirige avec ses hommes vers
l'ennemi peut-être espère-t-il pouvoir
colmater les brèches avant qu'elle n'ait
laissé passer trop d'hommes
c'est une erreur le roi étant présent
sur le front
ces soldats sont réduits au silence le
roi n'a pas non plus prévu la présence
des arquebusiers impérieux les français
se retrouvent soudain prise en embuscade
abattu l'un après l'autre par ses arcs
buzy
l'armée française est aussi nombreuses
que l'armée ennemie mais elle est
éparpillé le beau frère de françois
charles d'alençon a planté son camp très
loin du champ de bataille il ne recevra
jamais les ordres du roi et ne le
rejoindra jamais il finira par sonner la
retraite sans avoir combattu les
français sont battus parce qu'ils sont
pris par surprise leur artillerie n'est
pas efficace à ce que la cavalerie d'une
française charge devant les canons les
espagnols les fantassins espagnols les
arquebusiers espagnol attaque
tu à bout portant les chevaliers
français qui sont enferrés les uns dans
les autres qui sont pris dans la pluie
dans le brouillard dans un terrain tout
à fait impraticable pour la cavalerie et
finalement c'est une hécatombe une
hécatombe sans précédent il faut revenir
peut-être ou un siècle avant un siècle
et demi avant avec les grandes batailles
de la guerre de cent ans pour trouver
une hécatombe de la noblesse française
aussi important
l'armée dispersé de françois 1er est
vaincue et les morts sont innombrables
les capitaines du roi c'est chambellan
ses amis d'enfance
les héros de marignan ainsi que les
vieux maréchaux de charlot 8
françois a tué plusieurs officiers
espagnols avant que son cheval ne soit
abattu sous lui
il a continué à se battre à pied avant
d'être blessé et capturé il n'a accepté
de rendre son épée aux comptes delannoy
vice roi de naples
afin d'être sûr que les paires royal
soit reçue dignement d'autres nobles
français parmi lesquels anne de
montmorency et henri d'albret roi de
navarre ont également été capturés
seul le duc d'alençon mari de marguerite
a pu s'échapper
il mourra peu après son retour en france
de honte
selon certains
françois est immédiatement conduit à la
forteresse de pizzi gayton où il va
rester trois mois
c'est de là qu'il écrit à sa mère la
célèbre lettre où il lui dit j'écris
pour vous avertir comment se porte le
ressort de mon infortune de toute chose
nommé demeurait que l'honneur et la vie
qui est sauvé
le roi refuse les conditions humiliantes
qui lui sont imposées par un messager de
l'empereur henry d'albret s'évade de
prison et regagne la france à la suite
de cette évasion le roi de france est
transféré à naples dans une prison plus
sûres il comprend que son seul espoir de
recouvrer la liberté est de négocier un
traité de paix avec charles quint
il convainc lannoy de l'emmener en
espagne et arrive en août à madrid
l'enfant soit prévenue mais reste en
captivité pendant à peu près une année
une première partie de captivité en
italie tout à fait confortable ensuite
vers barcelone où il sera même accueilli
en principe il fait il imposera les
mains pour guérir les écrouelles on l'a
clamera et puis arrivé à madrid pendant
trois mois à peu près là ce sera
quasiment un cul de basse-fosse
montmorency et marguerite de navarre
avait déjà été autorisée à entrer en
négociation avec l'empereur romain
germanique
l'obstacle principal restait la
bourgogne charles quint insiste pour que
françois luce est ce du che mais celui
ci refuse obstinément les pourparlers de
paix reprennent en octobre les
conditions proposées par marguerite sont
de nouveau refusé par l'empereur et elle
rentre en france
la ruse semble être la seule voie qui
reste au roi de france s'il veut jamais
échappé à sa prison ils s'en rendent
compte et décide finalement de signer le
traité tout en n'ayant aucune intention
de le respecter
le 15 décembre ils informent l'empereur
qu'il accédera à toutes ces requêtes et
le traité de madrid est signée le mois
suivant
finalement c'est la france où le roi de
france et des diplomates français qui
vont craquer les premiers qui vont
considérer qu'il est plus important de
faire revenir le roi en france fût ce au
prix d'une promesse bourguignonne que de
le laisser dans le royaume
et je précise car ça n'est pas sans
importance pour la suite françois
premiers signes la veille de la
signature du traité officiel une
protestation
considérant qu'on lui arracher son
consentement sous la contrainte et donc
ce qu'il va signer le lendemain n'est
pas légitime n'est pas légal et n'est
pas valable
françois promet de renoncer à la
bourgogne la flandre et l'artois est
également l italie henri d'albret doit
lui renoncé à la navarre espagnole et
restituer le patrimoine du connétable de
bourbon et de ses partisans
enfin il livre en otage un charles quint
son fils aîné le dauphin françois et son
cadet henri d'orléans
jusqu'à la ratification du traité par le
parlement il doit également épousé la
soeur de l'empereur eléonore d'autriche
le 15 mars 15926 après un an de
captivité
françois 1er retrouve sa liberté ce
conflit fut appelé la guerre de quatre
ans ce fut une période d' invasion de
souffrance de larmes de lourds impôts et
d'innombrables pertes humaines
[Musique]
le retour du roi en 15 126 est comme un
second couronnement temps de nobles ont
disparu à pavie qu'il faut nommer
d'urgence des responsables au poste
vacant à la cour une des premières
préoccupations du roi et de son conseil
est également de se soustraire aux
conditions inacceptables du traité de
madrid tout en ramenant sains et saufs
les deux enfants royaux
[Musique]
or françois 1er a eu bon dieu un nombre
incalculable de maîtresses
madame de pisseleu madame de
châteaubriant la belle ferronnière
évidemment celle d'ailleurs je crois
tout le monde le dit qui lui a donné la
dernière des maladies parce que il a
souffert d'une bonne galanterie françois
1er avant de mourir elle était malade
jusqu au dernier degré la belle
ferronnière et tuent également madame de
toury qui habitait du côté de chambord
et c'est pour elle qu'il est allé
construire d'ailleurs tout à côté de
chez elle le château de chambord
[Musique]
sa première épouse étant décédés et la
nouvelle n'étant pas encore arrivé leroy
rencontre celle qui sera la plus aimée
et la plus influente de toutes ses
maîtresses anne de pisseleu délit elle
n'a que 18 ans c'est une jolie blonde
sensible qui est un vrai goût pour l'art
louise de savoie et marguerite de
navarre lui porte une grande estime et
la présente au roi la guerre de quatre
ans a laissé le domaine de l'art en
jachère
tous les fonds disponibles devaient être
affectés aux troupes et aux munitions
contrairement à ce qui s'était produit
après marignan on a vu peu de peintres
italiens à la cour de france peu
d'acquisitions importantes ont été
réalisées
[Musique]
l'école grec fondé à milan par françois
1er entreprises qu'il espérait bien
rééditer en france a pris fin en 15/100
22 avec la perte du duché la
construction de chambord a été
complètement arrêté et aucun nouveau
projet n'a vu le jour dès son retour le
roi reprend les travaux de construction
[Musique]
l'édification de chambord se poursuit
mais la cour n'est plus fixé dans la
vallée de la loire
à son retour de madrid le roi la déplace
à paris après le retour du roi d'espagne
en 15 126 une fois libéré le roi va
tenter de se rapprocher de la population
parisienne en particulier dont il a
besoin sur le plan financier en
particulier il va s'installer en
ile-de-france redonner au louvre le
statut de château royal et il va
également mener des opérations de
communication politique si on peut
appeler ça comme ça
en poursuivant notamment des grands
financiers que l'on va juger pour
mauvais comportement pour concussion un
lit de justice session particulière du
parlement en présence du roi se tient au
palais royal
en juillet 15 126 son but dénoncer les
graves erreurs faites par le parlement
pendant la captivité du roi françois
fait publier un édit audacieux par
lequel il interdit aux juristes
d'interférer dans les affaires d'état
autre que la justice
dans son ensemble le domaine de
compétence du souverain est renforcée et
même élargi dans plusieurs directions
il est en cela habilement second départ
un chancelier d'une grande fermeté le
cardinal antoine duprat
[Musique]
françois 1er laissera sans aucun doute
une france plus unie que lorsqu'il est
monté sur le trône l'instauration de la
règle absolue se fera très
progressivement le règne de françois se
terminera dans ce qu'on pourrait appeler
un absolutisme limité charles quint le
pressent de ratifiant enfin la paix
françois est forcé de faire un geste il
confié à l'émissaire espagnol un message
indiquant qu'il refuse de céder la
bourgogne à rome au même moment
jules de médicis succède à léon 10 et
devient pape sous le nom de clémence est
choqué par la défaite de la france en
italie en 15 125
il entreprend d'organiser avec l'accord
de la république de venise une coalition
pour expulser charles quint d'italie
françois 1er et les français ont été
écrasés par les impériaux à pavie en
cassant 25 au cours des mois qui suivent
c'est la mère du roi louise de savoie
qui tente de redonner au royaume de
france un statut de grande puissance à
l'échelle européenne
et pour ce faire elle va réussir à
négocier une alliance une grande
alliance qu'on appelle la ligue de
cognac avec le pape clément 7 et avec
d'autres princes italiens en particulier
pour combattre les impériaux françois
1er est impatient de loin les italiens
agressé l'empereur mais à ce stade il
n'est pas en mesure de participer
directement à l'opération
il espère encore obtenir de charles
quint par la voie diplomatique
la libération de ses fils des conditions
raisonnables le roi de france rejoint la
ligue
il promet le soutien de son pays mais
cache qu'il n'a pas l'intention
d'honorer cette promesse
en juin 15 126 la ligue de cognac est
signée par la france milan venise
florence et la papauté l'angleterre
refusent de s'y joindre
la première offensive militaire des
membres italiens échoue à l'audi ce qui
permet aux troupes impériales de
s'emparer de milan le pape vacille mais
françois 1er lui promet son alliance et
le soutien des troupes françaises
celle-ci n'arriveront jamais et la ligue
subir à de nombreuses défaites les
troupes impériales montre également des
signes de faiblesse charles k n'a pas
les fonds nécessaires pour payer très
longtemps ses armes et ses hommes ont
froid faim et se révolte
au printemps les langues des mercenaires
allemands et une armée espagnole sous le
commandement du connétable de bourbon
sont dans un état de mutinerie permanent
les deux armées fusionnent et commence à
marcher sur la capitale italienne
aux cris de piller ou payez rien ne peut
plus les arrêter
elle contourne florence et arrive très
vite à rome bien décidé à obtenir leur
dû le 6 mai débute le sac de rome
lorsque le connétable de bourbon
qu'avait pourtant combattu aux côtés de
françois 1er à marignan 15 115 il a
trahi le roi ensuite il a fait françois
prisonniers à pavie et après papy il
monte il descend vers rome et il va bien
et c'est la catastrophe
le connétable charles de bourbon et tués
dans la bataille mais ses troupes
envahissent la ville sa cage la ville
éternelle et pendant pratiquement un an
des soudards vont aller et venir dans la
ville ravageant les églises les
sanctuaires s'emparant des objets
précieux
c'est un événement sans précédent c'est
peut-être l'événement le plus important
du 16e siècle
il marque une victoire décisive du
saint-empire romain germanique dans le
conflit qui oppose charles quint à la
ligue de cognac
ainsi que l'entrée en guerre de
l'angleterre le pape s'abstenant
désormais de jouer aucun rôle dans cette
partie la france doit adopter une
nouvelle stratégie pour négocier au
mieux la libération des petits princes
un traité franco anglais signé en août
et françois premier envoi le maréchal
lautrec de l'autre côté des alpes pour
attaquer la lombardie les deux pays
déclare officiellement la guerre à
charles quint quatre mois plus tard
l'empereur et si furieux qu'il fait
durcir les conditions de détention des
deux enfants en italie l'armée française
subit défaite sur défaite en 15 129 le
roi de france a perdu l'espoir de
reconquérir l'italie la débâcle
française conduit le pape clément 7 à
s'allier à l'empereur charles quint au
nom de françois 1er
louise de savoie se rapproche de sa
belle soeur marguerite d'autriche tente
de charles quint pour répondre aux
besoins de paix
l'empereur aussi est très ouvert à
l'idée de conclure une trêve les deux
hommes finissent par se rencontrer dans
une ville frontalière de cambrai où
elles vont négocier ce qui est appelé la
paix des dames
on a été obligé de faire intervenir ses
dames tout simplement parce que les
relations personnelles entre le roi et
l'empereur c'était tellement envie mais
qu' il était souhaitable de passer par
des personnages féminins apaisant proche
des princes mais extérieur pour parvenir
à ce règlement
cette paix des dames à une clause
essentielle qui renverse si j'ose dire
ce qui s'était passé à madrid en 15 126
l'empereur acceptent de renoncer à la
bourgogne
moyennant quoi le roi de france s'engage
à lui verser une considérable rançon de
deux millions d'écus d'euros soleil le
traité de cambrai révision du traité de
madrid est signée en août 15 129
certains paragraphes sont assez
humiliant pour le roi de france
mais en même temps deux points le
satisfont ils conservent la bourgogne et
peut retrouver ses fils en échange d'une
rançon
[Musique]
les garçons alors âgés de 12 et 11 ans
ne regagneront la france qu'en juin 15
130 après quatre ans de captivité
françois se rend compte qu'il a échoué
en tant que chef de guerre et qu'il est
à l'origine des grandes souffrances
subies par son peuple et ses propres
enfants louise de savoie meurt en 15/100
peu de temps après avoir terminé son
rôle de conciliatrice elle est inhumée à
saint denis avec tous les honneurs dus à
son rang son fils trop bouleversée par
son chagrin ne plus assister à la
cérémonie
jusqu'à présent ces affrontements contre
charles quint non apportées à françois
1er
l'humiliation et souffrance on aurait pu
croire que ces expériences l'amènerait à
changer de voie mais il va encore se
lancer dans deux guerres contre son
ennemi juré
pour rivaliser avec l'empiré des
habsbourg le roi de france ne va pas
seulement recourir aux armes
il veut mettre un frein à la conquête du
nouveau monde par la couronne d'espagne
et devient ainsi le premier monarque
français à se lancer officiellement dans
l'exploration de l'amérique
alors évidemment françois 1er a une
grande idée en tête toujours cette unité
principale c'est essayer d'être meilleur
que l'espagne et pour cela et bien il se
lance dans l'exploration c'est à dire
qu'ils embauchent des explorateurs on
songe à jacques cartier qui part de
saint malo pour découvrir le canada
on songe à verrazzano qui part de dieppe
pour aller mettre les pieds dans ce qui
sera new york prochainement et tout un
tas de navigateurs qui vont longer les
côtes du brésil
il veut marquer son empreinte dans ce
qui sera le t2 les territoires nouveaux
et essayer de supplanter une voix de
plus l'espagne en 15/100 24 et 15 127
l'italien giovanni da verrazzano est
missionné pour explorer la côte
atlantique de l'amérique du nord entre
la floride et la terre neuve toujours à
la recherche d'or et de matières
précieuses le roi de france donne
l'ordre à jacques cartier et plus tard à
jean-françois de roberval de s'enfoncer
dans les terres d'amérique du nord à
partir de 15 cents 34 quartier
revendique pour la france ce qui est
aujourd'hui le canada met un coup
d'arrêt à l'avancé espagnole et prépare
les succès futurs de champlain ou xviie
siècle quartier entreprend trois voyages
de 15 cents 34 à 15 141
mais les résultats sont décevants
jacques cartier noue des alliances avec
les peuples de la vallée du saint
laurent
mais il ne trouve pas ce pourquoi il
était parti c'est-à-dire des matières
précieuses de l'or des diamants
il y a une forme de déception il ne faut
pas le cacher à la cour de françois 1er
la flotte française entre en contact
avec l' empire ottoman ce qui lui permet
de développer ses échanges commerciaux
en méditerranée après l'échec de la
ligue
françois voix tant soliman le magnifique
un allié potentiel contre le saint
empire romain germanique l'attrait de
l'italie est tellement grand pour le roi
très chrétien qu'il est prêt à
collaborer avec les infidèles et il
justifie cette alliance par ces mots si
les loups me viennent attaquer chez moi
il m'est bien permis d'appeler les
chiens pour les chasser
et
à l'époque de la paix des dames françois
est âgé de 35 ans et s'apprête à aborder
sa période la plus créative
plus jeune il avait englouti des sommes
considérables dans ses projets de
construction
il avait poursuivi les travaux de ses
prédécesseurs au château d'amboise et
démarrer la rénovation du château de
blois
il y avait également entamé la
construction du magnifique château de
chambord
inspiré par la renaissance italienne et
peut être conçue par léonard de vinci
après sa captivité
il fait de paris le nouveau foyer de sa
cour de ce fait les années 15 130 voix
les nouveaux chantiers se déplacer de la
loire vers paris et l'île de france à
paris leroy loge dans plusieurs palais
d'aucuns a été créée par lui
ils en arrivent à détester l'hôtel des
tournelles près de la bastille à
l'emplacement actuel de la place des
vosges à partir de 15 cents 34 la cour
restera au louvre
pour les occasions importantes françois
installe son trône
de l'autre côté du fleuve sur l'île de
la cité dans la grande salle gothique du
palais royal
il ya eu toute la période châteaux de la
loire chambord etc et puis dans la
deuxième partie de son règne il se
rapproche de paris
on le sait est à paris eh bien ils
décident de faire des grands travaux il
décide de faire abattre les
fortifications de philippe auguste
legrand de la grande tour de philippe
auguste et de le faire construire il
lance les premiers soubassement du
louvre alors il fait appel à des
architectes merveilleux comme pierre
lescot et ces gens là vont commencer le
grand chantier du louvre à l'origine du
12e siècle
le louvre avait été conçu comme une
forteresse à la périphérie de la ville
françois valy apporté de nombreux
changements
il crée une cour et fait entrer la
lumière dans les appartements en
démolissant le grand donjon médiéval
il faut attendre la fin de son règne
pour que pierre lescot à batley l'ouest
du vieux louvre et commence
l'édification du nouveau
le roi meurt quelques mois après en
avoir approuvé les plans
henry 2 et son épouse catherine de
médicis les feront exécuter tout en
apportant quelques modifications
la cour carrée par exemple est quatre
fois plus grande que prévu
françois premier décide de s'installer
en ile de france dans les années 15 120
il dira beaucoup moins dans la vallée de
la loire dans en ile de france il ya le
louvre il yad'autres château près de
paris et puis il ya fontainebleau
fontainebleau il ya une vieille
résidence royale que le roi décide de
transformer pourquoi parce que c'est au
milieu d'une forêt tout à fait
gigantesque où le roi peut s'adonner à
sa passion qui est la chasse c'est une
demeure de plaisance une demeure d'été
si l'on peut dire et le roi va faire
transformer le château dans les années
15 130 pour lui donner l'aspect d'un
palais renaissance mais c'est une
construction il faut bien le dire qu'il
reste un peu de bric et de broc et qui
n'a pas grand chose à voir avec les
grands pas les italiens de la même
époque
françois passe beaucoup de temps ou
louvre il se rend régulièrement à saint
germain en laye et villers cotterêts
mais c'est à fontainebleau qu'il se
plaît à trouver refuge
on raconte qu'un chien du nom de blot
s'étaient égarés ils découvraient une
fontaine inconnu jusque là et c'est
ainsi qu'on appelle à l'endroit
fontainebleau le lieu facile d'accès
depuis paris plaît beaucoup
situé à côté d'un magnifique lac est au
coeur de la forêt le château est un
ancien pavillon de chasse royale
une épaisse muraille médiévale entoure
une cour en ovale et un grand donjon
carré la reconstruction et l'expansion
de fontainebleau est l'un des projets
les plus importants de françois 1er la
réhabilitation commençant 15 127 et se
poursuivra jusqu'à la mort du souverain
qui parlait de ce château en disant tout
simplement chez moi françois 1er est
enchantée par fontainebleau c'est un
vieux château médiéval il se dit
également comme il l'avait fait pour
pour le château de philippe auguste à
paris pour en faire le loup isolé je
veux en faire un merveilleux château
renaissance pourquoi parce que ça n'est
pas très loin des tempes où il y avait
d'ailleurs sa belle maîtresses qui
habitait là c'est toujours la même il
faut toujours qu'ils maîtresse dans les
environs de françois 1er et ensuite il
veut en faire mieux qu'un château de la
loire et il réussit d'ailleurs puisque
il va faire une véritable école de
peinture école de sculpture
il va créer un univers de la peinture de
la littérature
il va créer une bibliothèque à
fontainebleau fontainebleau est devenue
le centre du monde à cette époque là
dès les premiers jours de son règne
françois n'a eu de cesse d'attirer à sa
cour les artistes de la renaissance et
les érudits férus de nouvelles sciences
ils avaient lancé des émissaires pour
acquérir les peintures sculptures et
manuscrits exceptionnels qui viendraient
enrichir ses collections engagé léonard
de vinci et andrea del sarto acheter des
oeuvres de raphaël et de michel-ange à
partir de 15 131 deux artistes italiens
rosso et le primate itx et travaille aux
côtés d'artisans français à la
décoration intérieure du château en
adaptant le maniérisme italien à la
sensibilité française
on voit défiler des petits et de grands
peintres sculpteurs mosaïstes et graveur
cette rencontre du maniérisme italien et
du mécénat français autour de
fontainebleau produit un style d'une
grande élégance qui mènera à la
formation de la première école de
fontainebleau
la galerie françois 1er ou a survécu le
travail de rosso a malgré tout été
beaucoup modifié au cours des siècles
le primate itx et à décorer un grand
nombre de chambres à coucher
mais il n'en reste pas grand chose
leroy rempli sa demeure enchanteresse de
ses biens les plus précieux c'est là
qu'ils accrochent les léonard de vinci
les raphaël les del sarto acquis depuis
le début de son règne
par la suite les sculptures rejoignent
les tableaux de sa collection
c'est également en 15 140 que leur fait
vrai sculpteur benvenuto cellini qui
avait cherché à attirer l'attention du
monarque par ses créations sans égale
reçoit le titre d'orfèvre officiel du
roi
sa célèbre salière et la nav de
fontainebleau sont les deux oeuvres qui
ont survécu au temps quand on lui montre
à la salle hier le roi pousse à une
exclamations de surprise et ne put se
lasser de l'admirer la collection royal
comprenait également des tapisseries le
roi en possédait plus de 200 certaines
avaient été fabriqués en france
mais pour la plupart elles venaient de
bruxelles et d'anvers dans ses galeries
avec ses fresques en toile de fond le
roi affiche ses trésors avec une grande
fierté fontainebleau devient un lieu de
culture exceptionnelle qui attire toute
l'europe
on en parle même comme d'une seconde
rome
s'il se consacre à bâtir certains des
plus beaux édifices au monde et à
développer ses collections d'oeuvres
d'art leroy n'oublie pas de cultiver son
image de protecteur des lettres il sera
même surnommé père et restaurateurs des
lettres dans la famille de françois 1er
on était on était cultivée en étaient de
fins lettrés et lui va être un fin
lettré
il va toujours s'entourer de poètes
d'écrivain on songe par exemple à
clément marot qui était son petit
préféré clément marot qui a d'ailleurs
été blessé lors de la fameuse bataille
de pavie et on songe aussi à guillaume
budé à qui il donne les pleins pouvoirs
il lui donne les pleins pouvoirs à tel
point que guillaume budé va voir
l'ambition et va réussir à réaliser la
création d'une bibliothèque royale qui
deviendra la bibliothèque nationale et
d'un collège qui sera le collège de
france en 15 130 il déménage la
bibliothèque royale de blois à
fontainebleau et la fin est installé au
dessus de sa galerie bien aimé la même
année il fonde le collège d'électeurs
royaux qui deviendra plus tard le
collège de france
celui-ci brise le monopole de
l'enseignement supérieur exercée par la
sorbonne et l'on n'y voit souvent dans
la salle de lecture
françois 1er et marguerite de navarre
comme en matière d'art leroy élargi sa
collection en envoyant des émissaires à
l'étranger à la recherche de livres et
de manuscrits rares en 15/100 37
ils signent l'ordonance de montpellier
instaurant ainsi le dépôt légal qui
oblige tout éditeur à remettre à la
bibliothèque royale
un exemplaire de chaque oeuvre le roi de
france désireux de faire de sa cour un
centre d'études invite plusieurs poètes
et savant humaniste dont il devient
proche selon la vision humaniste
la beauté est le reflet de la nature
divine parfaite
c'est ainsi que l'on voit naître des
créations qui dépasse les thèmes
religieux
[Musique]
françois 1er soutient également nombre
de grands écrivains comme le poète
clément marot ou l'incomparable françois
rabelais
lui-même écrit des poèmes sa soeur
marguerite de navarre est un poète de
talent dont les oeuvres ont traversé le
temps
françois 1er assez tôt a eu le sentiment
que le roi de france devaient
s'intéresser aux arts et également aux
lettres il est encouragé dans cette voie
par sa soeur marguerite qui
s'intéressent à la littérature qui est
elle même une femme écrivain et le roi
va donner sa protection un certain
nombre d'auteurs un certain nombre d'
humaniste y compris à certains qui sont
sur le plan religieux un peu protestants
on pense notamment à louis de berquin
qui traduira sme et le roi va en
particulier encouragé le retour aux
langues anciennes à l'étude du grec à
l'étude du latin et c'est dans cet
esprit qu'il va créer une ce qu'on
appelle le collège royal ancêtre du
collège de france où l'on va donner
décharge de professeurs à un certain
nombre de grands savants ce courant
novateur est accompagné d'un nouveau
danger ce sont les écrits de savant
humaniste chrétien qui ont appuyé les
demandes de réforme de l'église au début
du 16e siècle certains érudits comme le
prêtre hollandais erasme ont étudié les
bibles ancien écrites en hébreu et en
grec est constaté que le sens originel
avaient été perdus dans la traduction
erasme et d'autres comme l'allemand
martin luther désirait seulement que
l'on réforme l'église catholique et non
qu'elle se divisent mais leur remise en
cause des textes bibliques et leurs
critiques de la corruption contribuent à
alimenter un mouvement qui débouchera
sur la réforme au début sous influence
de sa soeur marguerite françois se
montre tolérant vers ce nouveau courant
et le considère même utile politiquement
car il a entraîné de nombreux princes
allemands à se retourner contre charles
quint son ennemi de toujours
lorsqu'il voit certains de ses amis
persécuté pour avoir diffusé des idées
jugées subversives
il prend leur défense mais le parlement
et la sorbonne poursuivre sans relâche
la mission qu'ils se sont donnés de
débarrasser la france des hérétiques
dans les années 15 120 il faut bien
prendre conscience du fait que l'europe
est en combustion sur le plan religieux
et que la papauté est en butte à une
sorte de schisme qui est le schisme
luthériens et le roi de france va
évoluer dans ses relations avec les
lettrés avec les savants et aussi avec
les réformateurs religieux en fonction
de ses relations avec la papauté
l'influencent de marguerite de navarre
sur son frère aussi grande qu'elle soit
ne peut l'emporter face à ce qu'on a
appelé la sphère des placards et à la
répression qui suit dans la nuit du 17
au 18 octobre 15 134 des protestants
placardent dans paris et d'autres
grandes villes de france des
proclamations contre la messe on en
trouve a même dit on sur la porte de la
chambre du roy est dans la boîte où il
gardait son mouchoir françois 1er ne
peut que revoir sa position vis-à-vis
des protestants
en quinze 139 des mesures sévères seront
prises à l'encontre des hérétiques
les protestants sont emprisonnés voire
exécutés en application de l'édit de
fontainebleau signé en 15 140
elles se poursuivront durant tout son
règne
[Musique]
la mort de francesco deux maris à fords
à duc de milan 15 135 offre à françois
1er un prétexte pour partir de nouveau
en guerre tout au long de son règne
françois 1er a rêvé d'être
définitivement du milan ac 1 115 la
conquête du ch et puis l'a perdu au
début des années 15 120 et au cours des
années suivantes il n'a eu de cesse de
mener des campagnes pour y retourner
même s'il ne faisait plus la guerre
forcément lui même en cassant 36 les
opérations reprennent quand françois 1er
se rend compte que charles quint n'a
absolument pas l'intention de lui
laisser le mille années alors que le
dernier duc de milan de la famille stora
est mort la guerre reprend donc en
15/100 36 et le roi s'empare de la
savoie et du piémont qui forme un petit
état de part et d'autre des alpes
mais il ne parviendra jamais à s'emparer
finalement dû me l'année durant la
guerre d'italie de 15 136,38 ils avaient
envahi le duché de savoie pour pousser
charles quint à lui rendre milan
l'empereur han avaient été s'irriter qui
l'avait défié le roi de france en un
combat personnel
mais cette fois après la leçon de la
bataille de pavie françois attend que
son adversaire fasse le premier pas
la stratégie de l'empereur romain
germanique et d'attaqués au nord en
picardie et au sud en provence françois
fait sortir de sa retraite son vieil ami
anne de montmorency dont l'expérience de
diplomate et d'amiral et reconnu par
tous et il lui confie la direction des
armées charles quint envahi marseille
mais malgré de lourdes pertes
anne de montmorency résiste au siège
l'année suivante il combat les hommes du
saint-empire parvient un statu quo en
picardie puis passe à la guerre contre
l'italie mais son action n'est guère
concluantes
françois 1er ne parvient pas à
reconquérir milan mais il s'empare d'une
grande partie des terres du duc de
savoie alliés de charles quint une trêve
est alors signé
leroy récompense anne de montmorency en
le faisant quinze 138 connétable de
france après quoi dit on leroy prenez
son conseil sur toute chose
le roi n'avait pas eu d'enfant de sa
deuxième femme eléonore la première
claude defrance fille de louis xii lui
en avait donné sept avant de mourir en
15/100 24 la première née louise était
morte bébé et charlotte disparaît à
l'âge de 8 ans la même année que sa mère
son premier fils françois et le dauphin
de france avec son frère d'un an son
cadet henri ils ont enduré de longues
années de prison en cas 133 françois 1er
propose d'unir son second fils à la
nièce du pape
la jeune catherine de médicis il s'agit
pour lui de se rapprocher de clémence
est pour leurs alliés contrôlent
empereur charles
mais le pape clément meurt dans l'année
et son successeur nouer une alliance
avec l'empereur rendant l'union valois
médicis sans aucun intérêt politique
pour la france
[Musique]
deux ans plus tard le dauphin françois
meurt subitement henry devient donc le
nouveau dauphin
il arrange ensuite le mariage de sa
fille madeleine âgée de 16 ans avec
jacques sène décosse mais elle meurt
quelques mois plus tard à edimbourg dans
les bras de son mari
il ne lui reste que sa plus jeune fille
la princesse marguerite
ne peuvent succéder un roi de france que
des mâles donc des garçons françois 1er
a eu trois fils de son premier mariage
avec claude de france la fille d'anne de
bretagne
mais malheureusement pour lui deux de
ses fils sont déjà morts au moment où
lui-même décès dans 447 l'aîné françois
et par an 15 136 et le plus jeune le
benjamin charland 15 145
reste le cas des henry qui va devenir
donc le roi henry 2 qui est d'ailleurs
un fils avec lequel les relations de
françois 1er ont été assez difficiles
dans la dernière décennie du règne
c'est probablement avec avec henri que
les relations de françois avec son fils
henri que les relations de françois 1er
et elle est moins favorable mais il
n'empêche que c'est lui qui lui succède
montmorency avait prôné une politique de
paix mais en 15 100 42
on repart en guerre durant sa brève
alliance avec charles quint françois
avait fait très attention de ne pas
mettre en péril son amitié avec le
sultan soliman dans ce moment critique
de la diplomatie européenne
françois 1er parvient à un accord avec
l'empereur au tome 1 contre l'empereur
romain germanique
cette alliance est la première à lyon
diplomatique non idéologique entre un
royaume chrétien et un empire non
chrétiens le fait que les chrétiens se
bat aux côtés des turcs contre des
chrétiens provoque un immense scandale
en europe et met dans l'embarras le
souverain français est un des événements
diplomatiques les plus intéressants les
plus surprenants peut-être du premier
16e siècle c'est l'alliance passée entre
françois 1er roi de france roi très
chrétien et le sultan soliman qui se
considère comme le seul empereur
finalement en europe qui est le prince
le plus puissant du monde à cette époque
et qui est à la tête d'un état immense
un état dont la religion officielle et
la religion musulmane et cette alliance
contre nature pourrait-on dire entre le
roi très chrétien défenseurs de l'église
de rome et le sultan soliman advient
verquin 136 c'est d'abord une sorte
d'alliance commerciale en réalité qui va
ensuite avoir des conséquences
militaires
françois 1er est obsédé il le sera
jusqu'à la fin de ses jours par milan
par les états italiens
bien et il se dit comment faire et bien
il a tout simplement l'idée de se mettre
d'accord avec les turcs c'est à dire que
les turcs à ce moment-là caressait le
rêve d'aller en hongrie il ne dit rien
il les laisse faire il ne réagit pas
évidemment charles quint n'est pas
content puisque ils arrivent jusque dans
les faubourgs deviennent les turcs
on sait d'ailleurs que le croissant turc
à vienne et les viennoiseries comme les
croissants du même nom viennent de cette
période là et françois 1er se frotte les
mains et il se met d'accord avec soliman
ils laissent envahir landry quitte à
d'avoir bac faire appel à ses services
ensuite contre charles quint la guerre
reprend donc en 15 242 françois 1er a
maintenant pour allier seulement 1er et
charles quint encore une fois henri 8
malgré la prise de nice par la flotte
franco ottomane les français restent
incapables d'avancer tandis que
l'invasion menée par charles lui même
dans le nord de la france remporte un
certain succès avant qu'il n'abandonne
la partie est une nouvelle paix soit
conclu en 15/100 44 selon le traité de
crépy françois pense que son troisième
fils charles sera bientôt mariée à la
nièce de l'empereur et se verra alors
offrir milan mais celui ci meurt
prématurément les termes du traité de
vienne nul et la perte de son fils
préféré laisse le roi inconsolable
au cours des cinq dernières années de sa
vie leroy lutte contre la maladie
entre les crises il continue à montrer
une vigueur extraordinaire voyage dans
différentes parties du royaume chasse
dès qu'il peut parfois depuis sa litière
le 28 janvier 15 147 la nouvelle de la
mort d'henri huit touches le roi de
france en mars tandis qu'il se rend à
paris pour assister à un service à sa
mémoire en notre dame
il est arrêté par la maladie au château
de rambouillet le 20 mars
se sentant mourir il appelle les deux
enfants qui lui reste à son chevet
plusieurs fois dans la semaine qui suit
il bénira henry et lui donnera ses
dernières instructions françois 1er
meurt le 31 mars 15 147 à l'âge de 52
ans
[Musique]
on
à l'âge de 20 ans françois 1er montré
des talents prometteurs deux diplomates
et deux chefs militaires mais la montée
en puissance de charles quint fit
pencher l'équilibré en sa faveur
mais le roi de france ne parvint pas à
s'adapter
ses rêves d'expansion coûteront cher à
son pays tant aimé sa campagne pour être
élu empereur en 15/100 19
l'extravagant camp du drap d'or en 15
120 les années de guerre en italie et la
rançon prévue par le traité de cambrai
entraîneront la levée d'impôts drastique
et laisseront sur les champs de bataille
les meilleurs soldats de france
pourtant françois 1er ne lâchera pas son
rêve d'italie il montrera la même
instabilité dans sa politique à l'égard
de la religion
tolérant envers la réforme durant les
premières années de son règne il finira
par laisser le champ libre à la
répression les persécutions contre les
protestants conduiront la france dans
une guerre civile qui dévastera le pays
pendant des années son règne n'aura pas
connu l'agitation populaire emblématique
de la fin du xvième siècle et du xviie
siècle
peut-être parce que de son temps
l'économie rurale du pays a retrouvé son
élan vers 14 150
mais au milieu de son règne pourtant on
commence à voir se développer des signes
d'instabilité
l'agriculture ne parvenait pas à combler
les besoins d'une population croissante
l'inflation plongeait de plus en plus de
gens dans la pauvreté le chômage et la
criminalité allaient en augmentant et la
couronne devait bientôt faire face à la
faillite à cause des dépenses de guerre
mais le règne de françois 1er par est
pourtant d'une importance capitale
des changements fondamentaux ont pu
s'opérer dans les domaines de
l'administration de la politique de
l'économie de l'éducation de la religion
des explorations et surtout de la
culture pour certains aucun souverain
depuis charlemagne n'avait eu une
influence plus grande sur la
civilisation de la france françois 1er
n'est pas connu pour ses reds héroïque
datant du moyen-âge mais pour la vie
intellectuelle et artistique de sa cour
sa grandeur réside dans son rôle de
mécène de la renaissance française
lorsqu il naquit en 14 294 la france
était encore gothique
lorsqu'il est mort en 15 147 la
renaissance française était proche
d'atteindre son apogée il avait réalisé
là un exploit peu de règne ont laissé un
héritage culturel aussi marquant aucune
époque n'a davantage vénéré l'étude que
la renaissance
les érudits s'efforçait alors de
redécouvrir la sagesse perdu de
l'antiquité en revisitant de manière
approfondie l'art et la littérature de
la grèce et de rome et aucun roi ne
s'est senti aussi proche de la période
antique
[Musique]